[Applause]
i didn't really
realize the impact of it at the time and
people would tell me that there were
parties all over the country it was like
super bowl it was there was people left
work early i'm so afraid to tell people
i mean i just
susan
i'm gay
there have been many many people before
me uh stepping forward and saying that
they're gay uh certainly i'm the first
lead character and it surprised people
because we didn't start the series with
me being gay
that felt great
that felt so great
and it felt so loud
we started with me being a heterosexual
woman and then she finds out she's gay
which is a kind of a risk when people
fall in love with a character and say
they like the character and then all of
a sudden you say oh by the way i'm this
which supposedly everyone in society
does not like that's that's a big risk
i'm something a little tension that's
right tense tension i have tension yes
you can read vibes yeah good she's happy
going through and i think she's gonna be
relieved when
she can just be ellen again ellen you're
brave to do the things you do
it's fun to talk about right now and
it'll be a cool thing for a while and
then everyone will get back to work i'm
just so proud of her and i've seen
what it's done for her and how much
freer she is and i just i love her very
much 20 years from now we'll talk about
wasn't it crazy how the country went
nuts and that's the thing you keep
hearing the question you know is america
ready was america ready it's you know i
don't think anybody's ever ready for
whenever anybody's the first to do
something i'm not saying i was the first
to do this but for television i i was
but nobody's ever ready you can't just
wait for
america to be ready for things and and
that's how
we affect chains
ellen
ellen
over here
[Applause]
it's like if something works let's make
a million more shows exactly like that
and nobody's willing to to risk and try
anything new and we did something that
everyone was scared and and just waiting
to to say ah we told you that would not
work it would fall apart it would ruin
your career and uh the fact that we have
done this i hope that more people will
take a chance and show a little more
diversity on television
we exist there are gay people in society
you know there are people of color in
society just
why don't we show what really happens in
life instead of it's like if we had
leave it to beaver on still that just
does not apply anymore it didn't apply
then
you know
nobody was named ward
[Music]